♪ ♪ ♪
- Les grands hôtels ne sont pas
encore pes vedettes
ne sont pas arrivées.
Mais tranquillement, la Ville
Reine se prépare pour le TIFF.
Et après deux ans en formule
hybride, le festival fait
son retour en présentiel.
Le PDG du festival s'en
réjouit et confirme que très
peu d'événements seront tenus
en ligne.
♪ ♪ ♪
Il n'y pas que les salles
de cinéma qui reprendront vie.
Après un hiatus forcé, c'est
aussi le retour des grandes
soirées du TIFF : un
incontournable du calendrier
mondain de Toronto. Ce soir,
on se prépare à accueillir
des invités qui se rendront à
ère soirée de la saison,
celle qui ouvre le bal
des célébrations à deux semaines
du début du festival. Ici aussi,
on a laissé tomber le format
hybride : des canapés et des
cocktails, pas de masque ou
de distanciation sociale.
L'hôtesse de la soirée, Natasha
Koifman, organise cet événement
chez elle depuis une vingtaine
d'années. Ce soir, elle reçoit
presque 300 personnes.
Mais ces soirées
hollywoodiennes ne sont pas
qu'une excuse pour faire
la fête. Elles rassemblent des
investisseurs, des producteurs,
des acteurs, des entrepreneurs;
toutes sortes de personnes
qui sont venues brasser
des affaires.
Une réalité que confirme ce
producte, qui confie
avoir déjà conclu des ententes
lors de soirées comme celle-ci.
Et ce ne sont que les invités
qui brassent des affaires.
En plus des convives,
une cinquantaine de personnes
sont employées lors d'une
soirée comme celle-ci.
isiniers, serveurs
barmans, DJ : autant de métiers
qui ont presque disparu avec
la pandémie et  qui reviennent
en force cette année.
"Il y a toute une industrie
derrière une soirée comme
celle-ci", explique Paolo
Pusateri, qui est propriétaire
d'une ene traiteur.
À elle seule, cette soirée
représente près de 10 000 $ pour
l'homme d'affaires. Et les deux
semaines du TIFF sont parmi
les plus occupées de la saison,
juste après l'Action de grâce.
♪ ♪ ♪
Une saison occupée qui
permettra de renflouer
les coffres après deux ans
d'accalmie.
Car au-delà du glamour et
des paillettes, le TIFF demeure
un des événements culturels
les plus lucratifs au pays
avec des retombées économiques
de plus de 150 millions de
dollars.
Ici Yasmine Mehdi,